Welcome back to Google
Developers Weekly
for January 28, 2014.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the
world of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
Starting the week's
festivities, we head to London,
where Mano Marks invites GDE
Stephen Gray-- no relation,
so far as I'm aware-- to show
us how he added ground overlays
and weather using
the Maps SDK for iOS.
Steve's app uses a tile overlay
to tone down the Maps styling
and remove Map labels, giving
a nice and clean background
for weather data.
But the Maps team wasn't
done with a single episode
here on GDL.
Paul Saxman covered the
basics of adding markers
to your Map using the
Google Maps Android API V2.
So don't miss either
show, geo-developers.
We then head up the road
from our main campus
to the Google San Francisco
office, where Chrome guru Peter
Lubbers hosted the San
Francisco HTML5 user group.
This week's event
focused on WebGL.
Peter also put on a microphone
to be part of the second Office
Hour session for Udacity CS256,
joining Chris Wilson and Sean
Bennett to tackle
questions around lessons 4
and 5 in this fast-paced
mobile web development course.
We record every single one
so you never fall behind.
We then invited Open
Source maven Cat Allman
to the studio, who interviewed
Googler Jeremy Allison to talk
on the Samba project,
the standard Windows
interoperability suite of
programs for Linux and Unix.
And our studios aren't
open to just Googlers.
Mamie Rheingold interviewed
4 young coding member
of diy.org, an online
community for kids
to learn skills,
discover cool projects,
and meet other awesome kids.
Hear how they learned to
code and get inspired.
And up in Seattle, where
they know just a thing or two
about clouds, Laurence
Moroney and Brian Dorsey
of the Cloud Platform
team took questions
on what Cloud
means to customers,
and how Google offerings
could get even better.
From New York, Ibrahim
Ulykaya took a look
at best practices
for YouTube's APIs
on iOS, including YouTube
Direct Lite for iOS.
Then Amy Quispe and
Eric Leichtenslag
took the time to walk
through the new Google
mobile ads features in
Google Play services
and explain how to migrate away
for the standalone AdMob SDK.
The Google Glass team took some
time recently to experiment
with games on Glass.
The games are quick
and fun, and we
hope they inspire
our Glass developers
to start their own projects.
Go to g.co/glassminigames
to find out more.
And Dart Flight
School is coming soon.
You can learn Dart at one of
these awesome events taking
place around the globe.
You'll learn Dart and get
to explore great frameworks
like Polymer and Angular.
Go to dartlang.org and
search for flight school
to sign up now.
And every year,
Google Code-In finds
amazing teenage programmers
from around the world
and awards them a four-day trip
to Google in Mountain View.
This year's 20 winners
have been announced,
and you can read
about them on our blog
at
googledevelopers.blogspot.com.
Congratulations to the 20
winners and the hundreds more
who entered.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.